hey we've been talking about Donald
Trump's recent friendly behavior with
regard to a number of different violent
dictators and extremist regime heads
this includes kim jeong-hoon from North
Korea who Donald Trump recently again
praised saying he's a smart cookie and
that he'd be honored to meet him but
also another one of those foreign
leaders was Rodrigo Duterte the
president of the Philippines who has
supported the barbaric extrajudicial
killings of drug users and drug dealers
in his country he's admitted to having
murdered multiple people while he was
mayor of a town in the Philippines whose
name I forget right now the alt-right
likes to talk about people being cocked
pat as you said yesterday when we were
chatting about this Donald Trump has
actually been cooked here by Rodrigo
Duterte Donald Trump praised Rodrigo
Duterte said he had a great conversation
with Rodrigo Duterte and then said he
would be honored to have Rodrigo Duterte
come to the White House and Rodrigo
Duterte has said no thanks I will not be
coming to the United States to meet with
the President of the US I'm too busy to
do that I think Trump was cooked here in
the colloquial sense of the word I think
the reason why Rodrigo Duterte decided
not to attend this White House visit was
because that would reflect badly on his
native population the Filipino people
are not in support of Donald Trump
around the election they asked the
Economist ask different countries how
they would vote if they were voters in
the United States presidential election
and the Philippines had 65% for Hillary
Clinton and around 13% for Donald Trump
so he is not popular and that looking
particularly good yeah the country that
has the admitted mass murderer as
president is saying yeah Trump's just
too extreme for us we don't we don't
like the guy so this is total backfire
for Donald Trump right he sends an
invitation to just a brutal brutal world
leader admitted mass murderer which
confirms that Trump has no standards
whatsoever when it comes to who he's
willing to invite to Washington who he's
willing to praise who is willing to be
friendly with on the international stage
and then now it makes Trump look even
worse because the guy rejected the in
the
and some might say hey listen doTERRA
days a world leader there's a lot going
on in East Asia right now and he's busy
with the foreign leaders over there but
that doesn't really appear to be the
case as Pat is pointing out it seems
that the Filipino people have a genuine
dislike for Rodrigo Duterte
and I mean this is just a dramatic
backfire for Trump right praising the
guy saying he likes what Duterte is
doing to rid the country of the war on
the problem with drugs and then the guy
is not even willing to come to the u.s.
to meet with Donald Trump and
invitations I'm sure get rejected all
the time because maybe these other world
leaders are just too busy or it just
doesn't fit their agenda at the time but
maybe that's why you shouldn't make the
invitations in public life for Krampus
for whom projecting strength is
important how on earth is getting turned
down by the leader of the Philippines
project strength at all I mean Donald
Trump is shaping up to be an incredibly
weak president in just about every way
and of course he's doing the penis cut
size contest equivalent of international
diplomacy which is starting to send
rockets and bombs to different places
but really not projecting strength in
any way well both these guys have
outrageous proposals for solving the
drug epidemic in their respective
countries for Rodrigo Duterte that means
encouraging vigilantism and for people
to go out there and kill drug dealers
and users and for Trump it means
building a border wall because of course
Trump thinks that the wall will stop all
drug inflow to the country he has been
talking about how he is going to stop
all drug problems by allowing the free
roaming killing of both dealers and
users who have not even been confirmed
to be dealers or users so anyway we can
tell a lot about Trump based on the
people that he's been praising around
the world can't we big discussion about
this on our reddit discussion forum
which you can find at david pakman.com
slash reddit today's program is made
possible in part by Gamefly which is
sort of like netflix for video games
they've got over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can also stream games you don't even
need a
in console or a computer because you can
stream games through your Amazon fire
stick or Roku box and then use your
mobile phone as the controller you can
play as many games as you want for one
monthly fee and if you find some games
you want to keep you can buy them for a
low used price never with due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
30-day free trial at Gamefly offer.com
slash TDP s the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included no contracts and you can also
stream the games I think I mentioned
that you can also rent games through the
mobile app get a free 30 day trial for
David Pakman show viewers and listeners
and support our show at Gamefly
offer.com forward slash TDP s